let's talk about what's going on with
will chamberlain because as we talk
about our cultural decay and our
institutional collapse will chamberlain
has tweeted out a law clerk by the name
of elizabeth deutsch
he says in his humble opinion she's the
most likely person to have leaked the
draft supreme court opinion in dobbs
purporting to overturn roe v wade he
says a disclaimer i have no inside
information this threat is speculation
based almost entirely on publicly
available information i could easily be
wrong
now
apparently he's being threatened that
he's gonna get sued over this which is
just laughably stupid elizabeth deutsch
is arguably not a public figure but
guess what people can become public
figures
whoa
now
will prefaces he doesn't know for sure
it's a speculation and you're allowed to
speculate and will is also a lawyer so i
think he knows what he's doing but i i
think this is this is a real interesting
thread because of how the reaction has
been let me see if i have this one from
eric swalwell eric swalwell you know you
love me farted on tv he said under
supreme court law as a public figure i
take a lot of defamatory attacks because
bar is too high to sue ms deutsch is not
a public figure and would likely have a
strong defamation case against will
chamberlain republicans are bullies but
they always back down when challenged
ron coleman says you are not scaring
anyone but you are getting some some of
us pretty excited
and then it's elmer fudd saying i love
civil litigation
okay okay so here's here's the gist i'll
just give you the simple version
she is
um according to this threat from will
she's an uh like a reproductive rights
activist is that what they how they call
it
her academic background isn't uncommon
he says things get interesting every law
student has to write a note a long legal
research paper making a novel argument
by the law hers is about reproductive
rights and abortion she argued that
obamacare's non-discrimination provision
should be interpreted to force catholic
hospitals to perform emergency abortions
aggressive argument but hey law students
are aggressive he says while in law
school she wrote a new york times op-ed
about reproductive rights her career
page on linkedin doesn't reveal that
much until we dig a little further
thanks to her new york times wedding
announcement of course we know that she
clerked for judge nina pillard pillard
was one of the dc circuit judges
appointed by obama and forced through by
harry reid to blunt up the filibuster
she's stridently pro-choice perhaps not
shocking after her clerkship she got a
gruber fellowship at the aclu for a full
year working on abortion and
reproductive rights none of this proves
anything deutsche's career seems pretty
focused on abortion but without some
connection to josh gerstein the
journalist who received the leak there
would be no reason to suspect her
let's go back to that new york times
wedding announcement the bride and groom
she met at yale she is a lawyer he is a
journalist
isaac arnsdorff just got hired by the
washington post as a national political
reporter of course he's on the trump
beat
but he but where has he written in the
past politico sharing a byline with josh
gerstein interesting uh so that's that's
that's the connection says uh looks like
gerson and they are still bros chatting
on twitter interacting as recently as
last year to conclude we have a
currently setting supreme court law
clerk whose career has been almost
solely focused on abortion she wrote a
law school note on abortion short op-eds
about reproductive rights spent a year
working on abortion at the aclu clerked
for a pro-choice judge and just so
happens that her husband is a journalist
sharing bylines with josh gerstin at
politico and it looks like they're still
friends sharing a byline means they
worked together like they they they've
shared this story that's published so
they know each other for sure he says i
don't know that elizabeth deutsch leaked
the draft opinion but i certainly think
someone who has spent much of their
academic and professional life fighting
to expand the right to get an abortion
could be desperate enough to do so i
think it's a uh an interesting threat
and some good journalism journalistic
work he didn't publish any private
details outside of here's a person who
publicly works for the court and we're
looking for a leaker robbie suave says
what is the argument that it's okay to
do this but not to reveal the name of
libs of tiktok
ian milestrong she's not anonymous for
one and secondly will didn't publish
deutsch's home address she's not
anonymous she's literally a law clerk
someone leaked the information we're
going to start looking who the publicly
available information on law clerk says
libs of tick tock's name was not in in
the public but my argument on that one
was always i disagree with it but
there's an argument to be made about the
journalistic um
issue around whether or not someone's
who someone is is is uh should be public
knowledge considering libs of tick tock
had 600 000 followers and was
influencing politics i think the
reporting was warranted but the name
didn't serve a purpose posting the home
address was crossing the line as for
this this is not an anonymous person
this is someone who has stamped law
clerk at the supreme court under their
name all of this is in the press libs of
tick tock's information may have been
public as they argue but it was in like
registries it was in like real estate
licenses there was nothing saying
linkedin person libs of tick tock like
this individual has now the threatening
to sue i wonder if will is over target
on this one and he actually found who
may have leaked the also making popular
beams on twitter and not even making
popular means sharing videos on twitter
of other people of other people and
being at the highest court in the land
that those are like two different
categories of power
oh yeah posting memes is way more
powerful i'm sorry i just don't buy that
this isn't a public person you know you
work for a member of congress that's
publicly known um you know if you tweet
something as a member of congress i
guarantee you the new york times or
whoever will will go after you so you
know i think look will is an incredibly
smart guy um he's very careful i imagine
he went through all of these clerks and
kind of did some process of elimination
and look i mean this is really
interesting you know the media is not
going to do anything about this right
they're not going to look for the leaker
they're happy it happens so oh yeah i
think it's going to have to be on on
people like will and other sluice
this is the media as well and so that's
part of how we're changing what the
media is right we're so used to being on
the app being outside of the building
looking in that the media usually refers
to the establishment but
we're we're taking over we're we're
taking that space so the corporate press
i think is usually even this is
corporate press this is this is not team
cast as a corporation that's not we're
usurping that title the bad i mean this
is the one the good you guys are here
come the semantics that are complete
um you know what's been crossing my mind
that it's a spouse somebody talked to
their spouse it's so easy to go home
after work and lay in bed all stressed
out and just blab about what you did at
the job so it's very well could have
been still they'd still have to get it
they had the physical 98 page draft
and apparently that's really limited in
terms of who could have i'm not saying
that this i don't know what this is tons
of journalists are married to people in
politics yeah it is one thing it is not
the the was the fourth estate i think
the press was supposed to be yeah yeah
no the fourth estate and what's the
third estate is that which one which is
it is the third state government i think
it's the third oh
whichever whichever estate is supposed
to be you know unlike the
representatives has
merged with journalism and now it's
paulism now it's a monopoly of states a
monopoly of estates
here's the here's another tweet mike
sternovich you said new talking point
just went out doesn't matter who leaked
adam schiff says i don't care how the
draft leaked that's a sideshow what i
care about is that a small number of
conservative justices who lied about
their plans to the senate intend to
deprive millions of women of
reproductive care codifying rho isn't
enough we must expand the court
oh incredible so a leak from the supreme
court is a sideshow this is this is an
interesting precedent how many more
leaks from the supreme court are going
to happen in the future now when some
progressive clerk doesn't like what she
sees these i'm telling you man
boomers
had scruples
i asked this question why is there why
can't you bribe a cop in the united
states
because the cop will arrest you on the
spot but why can you bribe a cop in
russia
it's still illegal to do
but there's no scruples they're not
worried about repercussions they're not
worried about being ostracized or
cancelled or anything like that
for the older generations they're
genuinely worried that if i step out of
line people will be mad at me
now you've got these law clerks who are
like i literally don't care
what anyone else thinks my tribe must
win
when you have two distinct political
factions
and within those umbrellas you have many
different ideologies like libertarian
conservative are kind of in the same
space but they really don't disagree
with each other just like progressives
and neolibers don't but they're in the
same space
what happens is we had one united states
and a republican would be like
i can't do that because
democrats you know i'm gonna get all the
flack from my colleagues in congress
that one goes too far
nowadays there it's basically come to
the point where left and right says i do
not care at all what the right things
the left must get this thing
so
the attitude now with cancel culture
um ethan klein really great example h3h3
he makes an offensive statement he
apologizes to his fans we all laugh and
be like look what you have to do but to
him he's like i don't care about the
right things because the right's not
paying my bills so i'll apologize if i
have to
that's where that's where we're at right
now there's no ethan can come out and
accuse anyone on the right of being
anything and there's zero there's zero
damage he will face
we had a d transitioner on the show
yesterday and i'm like i'm sure a bunch
of activists are gonna come and scream
in my face but they have zero impact on
my work or my show so why should i care
and that means when the boomers are gone
there's gonna be two distinct
political realities in this country you
said that there's one united states i
see 50 united states and the reason we
have 50 states is because just in case a
political faction attempts to cease
power at the federal level the states
have total recourse to resist that and
that means civil war or just means a
revolution no because
california will not tolerate a
republican revolution if the right goes
in the federal government takes over
california says no i don't think it has
to be a political revolution a
technological revolution
dude
a revolution of states the the issue the
issue with this is you know republicans
conservatives will always say federalism
will solve everything that we should we
should push things back to the states
but i do think you know it's important
to know who our enemy is here and
to tim's point i mean these are people
who think that the ends are always
justified and so
you know
why why would california listen to you
know something so i i'll i'll take a
different view here i think the most
important was the information war
and the reason why these divides are
happening is because the media has gone
so far to the left that is creating this
alternative reality
yes yes but uh well have you guys
i disagree a little bit i think social
media created a generation living in a
broken fractured world where there is no
truth but power
and then they got jobs in media and now
the new york times is being worn as a
skin suit as is the washington post
i mean look yeah kids using facebook
when they're 14 and they figured out how
to go viral now they're working in the
journal now they're at the new york
times sort of it was
news organizations funded by venture
capital who found the fastest path
towards making money was rage bait and
so you ended up with websites like
mike.com which initially started as ron
paul supporting and then went woke
because they were like this stuff works
you know what doesn't work for the right
what worked for the right was anti-sjw
we don't like the things they're doing
so we're going to complain about it
whenever they do it
what worked for the left was literally
lying about anything it's claiming that
cops are going around hunting down black
people russiagate covington justice
mollet ghost of kiev that's a new one
michael brown trayvon martin ahmed arby
lie lie lie lie lie like kyle written
now sly they do it nonstop all day every
day and it works every time these people
live in a chaotic dimension of flame
fire and destruction and they don't care
they've been wrong about almost every
major cultural story of the past decade
they don't care you will not change
their minds so when i pull up politico
quite literally having two articles one
saying ukraine did meddle and one saying
actually that was russian disinformation
but they never retracted the other one
how can these people exist how can their
brains function with such cognitive
dissonance that is the problem the
information wore yes but if these people
are in a cult and you can't reach them
then there's going to be fighting you
can but you got to figure out how
everyone can be reached every cult
member can be reached usually got it
there's a way and it's true the way to
do it is to show them they're not as
popular as they think
and what's insulating them from that is
social media censorship what i want to
know is why are republicans so keen on
bailing this industry out bailing the
news media out the same industry that is
publishing these politico articles the
same who's trying to bail them out
a bunch of republican senators
apparently they've jumped onto this amy
klobuchar build called the journalism
competition
this by the way
the uh the journalism competition and
preservation act i think i've discussed
it on the show before thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm we'll see
you all there